this is dave klein reading for
alessandro barbossa it's rare for a game
to offer a wholly new perspective for
how we can experience a familiar setting
and rarer is still for one to so
confidently have all of its mechanics
designed around it stray and adventure
puzzle game where you play as a cat
manages to not only delight in its
presentation but also in the many ways
it issues common puzzle mechanics to
focus on the abilities and limitations
of its protagonists it's a consistently
satisfying adventure with a charming
story about companionship that rarely
misses a beat across its well-paced run
time
[Music]
you play as a stray cat that is quickly
thrust into an entire world underneath
your own after a mishap that occurs in
the opening minutes of the story alone
in this neon soaked city that's beneath
a giant unmoving dome you quickly
befriend a small drone that becomes a
trusted companion throughout your
adventure and a vital translator for all
the other sentient robots that inhabit
the handful of regions you'll visit
[Music]
this drone called b12 also gives you
more options to interact with the world
around you such as being able to hack
doors to open them kill dangerous
flesh-eating aliens with a beam of
purple light or illuminate dark and
dreary avenues as you explore them
outside of the assistance from b12
however stray fully embodies the
abilities that being a cat would afford
you in this situation you've got a lot
of mobility to get around with
contextual button presses on reachable
surfaces letting you effortlessly jump
on down and around pretty much anywhere
you'd
[Music]
like this approach allows each leap to
look incredibly good too with detailed
animation work making your movements
look as natural and ballet-like as most
cats do when navigating their
environment you can chain together these
actions which makes platforming feel
fast and fluid providing a nice rush of
momentum as you hold down the jump
button and rotate the camera around to
guide yourself along a string of leaps
there are rare instances where you can
accidentally jump away from where you
initially intended and others where
coming down from a high perch can be a
bit more troublesome than getting up
because of how you need to rotate the
camera to see a platform to jump to
these moments however are fleeting
enough that it hardly breaks up the
thrill of being able to so easily get
around throughout stray you'll alternate
between small hub areas that you're free
to explore and more linear focused
portions which both highlight your
abilities in different ways the
verticality of the hubs help you
understand the limits of how high and
how far you can jump while also offering
neat secrets to find as you start
exploring small routes that only a cat
would likely be able to navigate
[Music]
linear portions are usually focused on
speed requiring you to chain together
jumps while also challenging your
understanding of what is and isn't
feasible given your small size the ebb
and flow between these two types of play
gives straight a delicately balanced
pacing that allows it to introduce new
tools for b12 or new enemies to
circumvent while never letting others
overstay their welcome as well as
letting you enjoy a freedom of moving
around its world at your leisure when
things simmer down
your mobility is key to solving stray's
many puzzles most of them rely on
identifying a path to an objective and
then either executing a series of jumps
or first constructing a path by moving
various elements around the world to
create one that you can navigate in
other instances you need to find objects
to wedge into the blaze of fans so you
can pass through or use your claws to
pull down parts of the environment to
expose a new pathway to platform up most
of stray's puzzles are contained within
small areas which makes finding the
solution relatively straightforward
they're never too challenging but also
not trivial so solving them is
consistently satisfying in later stages
more complex scenarios involve some
light stealth and dexterous movements
around a space which come at the right
time as by then you'll have a firm grasp
of how you're allowed to move about
stray's world there are a handful of set
pieces that aren't as enjoyable however
these mostly occur in the first half of
stray's adventure and usually involve
having to circumvent groups of enemies
that quickly jump and latch onto you in
numbers to bring you down it's not so
much that the puzzles involved with
these creatures are poorly designed but
rather that they often require you to
run around awkwardly avoiding these
enemies rather than giving you strategic
ways to deal with them this is
compounded by the fact that these
enemies sometimes can jump far higher
than you were previously led to believe
making the safety of vertical purchase
feel inconsistent there's only a handful
of these sections but there's no doubt
that they're the weakest in the journey
stray's distinct hubs are usually
introduced after these disappointing
sections and each one is packed with a
rich detail despite their relatively
small sizes there are numerous robotic
inhabitants to chat to if only by proxy
through your drone companion and smaller
side stories to uncover many of which
fill in the gaps of the core narrative
concerning a world that has not seen
humans for thousands of years touching
moments between several characters do a
great job of supplementing the core
theme of companionship through the lens
of these sentient ai discovering the
familial traits all on their own while
also dissecting the lack of empathy
their makers must have had to let things
get to the state in which you'll find
them it's delicately told and culminates
in a satisfying conclusion that doesn't
leave any questions lingering but
instead lets you reflect on the
relationships you made along the way
with warm fondness the hubs themselves
are also visually striking with a high
level of detail packed into their
construction the neon signage that
punches through the darkness illuminates
every crevice with bright colorful
lighting accentuated by eye-catching
reflections bounced by puddles on the
streets
shops and stalls all have distinct
designs that you can pick apart by
navigating around them whether it's
simply from the low angle of the
dimunitive feline protagonist or atop
shelves where there are many obstacles
to push out of your way onto the floor
outside the city districts cold and damp
stores are appropriately unwelcoming and
off-putting with some surprising
elements that sometimes make stray feel
like it's bordering on becoming a horror
game each new area you are introduced to
is immediately captivating to wander
around in and i enjoyed spending a long
time picking them apart
[Music]
stray's ultimate strength is how well
its overall design embodies the unique
perspective and capabilities of its
protagonists but it also doesn't rely on
this to be the only distinguishing
feature of the entire venture a lot of
the enjoyment throughout stray's runtime
comes from how well each scenario is
designed for the abilities of its feline
hero and how empowering it is to be able
to navigate its gorgeous hubs and
derelict cities with additional agility
on offer its puzzles are routinely
satisfying to solve and all work in
service of a charming story with a
satisfying conclusion with the pacing
only knocked slightly off by some
slightly less than stellar combat
scenarios in the first half
thankfully they're not prevalent enough
to detract from the otherwise
captivating adventure that stray is and
that it tells a tale that will likely
linger with you after the game's credits
have rolled
[Music]
[Music]
you